Traxxas hit us up and asked us if we
wanted to do a video for the corridor
channel obviously we love their RC cars
and that's something we totally wanted
to do but we need to give them an idea
that's both great as a standalone video
for people to watch on the corridor
channel and something that features how
cool and ridiculously fast their cars
are so we're gonna get to some
brainstorming should be a lot of fun I'd
like the idea of having feel like
deliver a secret message across the
battlefield I like it a little bit more
than Pizza that's because not quite as
serious about these taking over a hill
in trance car like it comes out of a
portal hold on I don't like how anime
pictures was it has steaks that are so
high in such a non serious situation
that it becomes funny
that's where reading because what's the
one with the Russians invading America
Oh Red John Red Dawn a teaspoon it's
like a kid like him driving this RC car
and dodging all the Russians and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
there's a kid driving a car down there
would never want to work with I don't
know man a foreign invasion yes the
deliver pizza across a foreign invasion
battlefield he's at home
his mom single mother out getting
groceries kids home alone
alright Russians take over
he's all up in home alone he's scared I
was like he doesn't know that he can't
get into the gun safe do all these
Russians are lying
literally landing or that he's got a
secret message out his neighborhood to
round up all the other kids to help to
beat the Russians so he's got he gets
his RC car out and throws it around the
neighborhood alerting all the kids
the Russians see the RC car driving they
saw and actually leave his house and at
the end he rounds up all the kids they
go there and the Russians find them
executed no the alternate ending is the
Russians find them and all the kids pull
out all their IRC cars and then there's
just like a kind of comedic battle scene
where all the cars bump into the
Russians get them in the shin no in the
Sandlot when they go to face off against
the team from across the neighborhood
yeah do something like that it was like
one kid and he's got an underdog team
and they're about to go off the biggest
baddest erasers or the other kids from
across town from the rich part of town
and they get together and they race of
course the underdogs win there's like a
key the smokes going across the
battlefield is to get to see explosions
while it's ripping it up you see
explosions in this too
what it explodes I can talk dude you
think kids you think rich kids don't
have bombs that shoot out of their cars
I don't know how about this kid rolls
out of bed gasping for breath and he's
like he kind of takes his self on out
he's like
I'm gonna die if I don't get chili or
pizza or some junk food and some other
goods on the other hand is like gotcha
this is our like a lender's commercial
and it's a Wendy's it cooks up a
hamburger slide to the Damayanti part a
little bag taped it down you just have a
Goldberg like character on the
rough-and-tumble team what's the
Goldberg like again you know Goldberg
from Mighty Ducks I'm gonna kid Goldberg
it's even got the orange only it was
always eating I know the archetype catch
her and sandlot yeah that time I think
it's the fat man he's good yeah the fat
90's kid everyone loves him he's got a
food problem yeah it's so easy yeah I
like the imagery of putting a hamburger
on top of an RC car and seeing that or
going around a race course but he needs
a reason to shred like was it running
from no no he's just one of the kids in
the race and he has this is just like
you said let's not make a man drew
Morgan let's do just not really since
there's someone who decides to retouch
the hamburger to his car I got an idea
the RC company they make a car but they
make him at stake for this car and it's
actually got such a powerful computer in
it the use of quantum pod new CPU the
ends up sucking in the soul the kid it's
the issue a recall they need to send all
the cars back this kid stuck his body is
stuck in this car and so the the goons
show up to the house to reclaim the car
because they actually be nice to
literally run drive for his life as the
car while being chased by goons so EPI
and he runs out about others in the room
for more fakery
and then they save this life and help
them out dude hold on wait why aren't we
just doing the Sam want the sandlot idea
well but it's like the same old story
it needs a twist means you're trying to
take a fundamental story element and
do that because it's what people are
used to seeing the difference between
the fundamental story element and a
fundamental story exactly even more
credible is the fundamental story we
take fundamental story elements and
create a new star dam in law we don't
just throw away two thousand years of
Court jurisprudence because we feel like
say the law is art man an art craft
creates laws yeah not just is the under
it's an underdog team it's a Halloween
video there's a guy it's the Headless
Horseman and his head pops off and falls
on top of an RC car neat how's that he
helps it
it helps him drive his head back to his
body fine let's follow this Headless
Horseman idea for a second here was just
saying it's it's a it's a horror thing
where there's like he's got a zombie
friend or like it's the Headless
Horseman himself technically it's got a
headless horseman driving his own head
back to him yeah great husband where is
the relationships where's the kid he's
like I should be scared by on judge
books by their cover like where's that
[Music]
I'm just saying like you're this head
driving around on the car people are
like freaked out so I scared so I also
want to burn you so the portal of 2017
legit on a horse what is he chasing his
head and his head rolls into the Traxxas
factory and lands on an RC car and he
runs in after and he tries to get it
back yeah yeah I think if they make sure
you staged it in like a village that has
like two villagers that want to burn the
Headless Horseman
there's my modern-day village so it's
like I don't know about this black magic
[Laughter]
yeah it's like that's what the villager
sounds like in 2017 nobody is just a guy
sitting as partaking about the head that
drove by five minutes ago get the bird
out he's getting farther away this 338
is an insignificant RAM for the distance
commendation that's what I think
villagers are like these days if you
want to role play as a villager in the
video of a now modern LARPing modern
LARPing well your villagers I bit my lip
really hard when I was making that
accent I got this flap of skin bouncing
on them oh man I was a good video
I certainly hope you'll consider
subscribing and if you aren't subscribed
so we hope you'll consider hitting that
notification button so these days on
YouTube you can subscribe and YouTube
still won't show you the video so if you
really actually don't want to be in the
hands of YouTube's algorithm you just
want to see those videos I'm gonna get
dang uploaded consider hitting that
subscribe button slash notification
button thanks